[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'un des grands enjeux de 2018 qui va
nous occuper beaucoup au moyen orient
2018 c'est cette rivalité entre l'arabie
saoudite et l'iran deux grandes
puissances qui s'affrontent sur
l'échiquier politique pour dominer
l'agenda
l'arabie saoudite qui est aussi aux
prises avec une période très critique de
transformation après des promesses de
modernisation de l'économie mais aussi
de transformation sociale et culturelle
et l'iran qui est aux prises avec un
mouvement de contestation qui est née
d'abord pour dénoncer l'augmentation du
coût de la vie mais qui s'est élargie à
des demandes de nature plus politique
c'est 2017 a été marquée par la défaite
du groupe armé ta islamique par la
coalition 2018 sera sans doute l'année
de la reconstruction et de la
réconciliation dans la mesure où ces
deux éléments seront prises assez au
sérieux
est-ce qu'on va arriver à redonner
espoir aux populations qui ont vécu sous
le joug du groupe armé islamique
va-t-on reconstruire suffisamment les
infrastructures de villes qui ont été
complètement anéanti par les combats qui
ont permis de loger le groupe armé état
islamique ou si au contraire on va
laisser en place un terreau fertile à
l'émergence d'un nouveau groupe
extrémiste ou retour en force du groupe
armé état islamique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il reste encore plusieurs lignes de
front en syrie mais sur une majorité du
territoire les armes se sont tues
est-ce qu'en 2018 les 5 million et demi
de réfugiés syriens enregistrés auprès
du haut commissariat aux réfugiés vont
vouloir rentrer dans cette série
auront-ils confiance qu'ils peuvent re
bâtir des vies qu'ils ont mises en
suspens vont-ils être forcé par les pays
hôte la turquie le liban et la jordanie
qui montre des signes de fatigue
importante pour rentrer dans une scierie
qui est encore anéantie par des années
de guerre civile